[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute machen wir eine
yogurette torte das war ein wunsch von
euch über instagram falls ihr auf
instagram nicht folgt spätestens jetzt
nach und nach zu nämlich ganz viel
mitspracherecht verlinkt ihr euch hier
unten in die infobox genauso wie alle
menge an gary shaw beim thema bin ich
starte nämlich direkt und wir gar nicht
lange drumherum fackeln das wird in
oberkochen seine noweck torte mit einer
leichten joghurt creme aber wir fangen
mit dem boden an und dafür nehme ich mir
ganz einfache butterkekse die werde ich
jetzt schön fein mixen gibt er gleich
noch etwa kakao und geschmolzene butter
mit dazu
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt alles miteinander
verrührt und auch schon mal meinen
tortenring auf 24 cm eingestellt ich
habe ein backpapier untendrunter gelegt
und darunter ein kickboard einfach damit
ich es transportieren kann und
eigentlich kennt ihr das auf meinen
videos dass ich direkt auf die
tortenplatte gebe aber der kühlschrank
ist so voll mit torten voll das
luxusproblem ich weiß aber ich habe zum
ersten mal keinen platz im kühlschrank
weil wir so viel gebacken haben in
letzter zeit natürlich alles gefilmt
haben
da stehst du familie und gut ja haben
sie bringt barmenia auf jeden fall und
ich werde das jetzt hier flach andrücken
und hab schon gemerkt ich habe jetzt
hier einfach butterkekse genommen ich
bin nun mal gern einfach kaufen
eigenmarke und cacau hinzu gefügt dann
hat man quasi kaum butterkekse wenn ihr
direkt kakaobutter kekse verwenden
möchte dann könnt ihr das natürlich auch
gerne tun
und während ich das verteile drücke ich
das auch richtig schön fest an
ich habe den boden jetzt einfach im
kühlschrank zwischengelagert und mache
jetzt so weiter mit meiner creme und das
prinzip ist wirklich total einfach und
anfänger geeignet also macht es
unbedingt nach und schreibt mir dann in
die kommentare
wie ihr das ganze fand ich werde jetzt
einmal die kalte schlagsahne stand ich
benutze kein sahne fest wir arbeiten
heute nämlich mit agar agar das ist
dieses stilmittel aus algen was aber gar
nicht nach algen schmeckt macht euch da
keine sorgen deshalb werde ich jetzt
einfach nur seine schön schlank genug
sein handmixer dafür muss zwischendurch
richtig heiß weil irgendwie habe ich das
gefühl dass die schlüssel nicht groß
genug ist aber es hat noch geklappt
freut euch nämlich in diesem video auch
zeigen ihr braucht nicht immer
glücklichen maschine das geht auch mit
dem handrührgerät weil das rezept
wirklich anfänger geeignet ist und auch
für leute die halt nicht so das
equipment da haben auch aber ich finde
so einen tortenring und so weiter und so
verstreichen das hat man immer da wollen
wir mal gerne backt aber nicht alle
haben eine küchenmaschine ich geht's
direkt rüber zum herd ich werde die
sahne
aber in der zwischenzeit auch in den
kühlschrank stellen ich gebe jetzt milch
und agger einmal in meinen topf verrührt
das kindchen frei und dann schalte ich
erst den herd ein
jetzt müsst ihr die ganze zeit rühren
und das ganze zwei minuten lang die zwei
minuten 10 übrigens erst ab jetzt wo ihr
diese kleinen bisschen seht und immer
rühren denn ihr wisst der milch brennt
immer super gerne an
den topf vom herd ziehen und dann den
griechischen joghurt dazu hören da
braucht auch gar nicht darauf warten
dass es abkühlt ich gebe auch direkt
zucker und vanille extrakt mit dazu
früher alles gut unter die masse ist
super super flüssig davon dürft euch
nicht irritieren lassen
ich habe jetzt hier auch in eine
schüssel umgefüllt weil gleich noch die
sahne dazu kommt aber ihr müsst es jetzt
kurz abkühlen lassen
ich würde mal sagen 15 minuten damit die
schönen steif geschlagene sahne jetzt
nicht in die warme und masse kommt uns
wird sie nämlich flüssig werden und das
wollen wir unbedingt vermeiden
daher warten wir jetzt einfach mal ein
bisschen ab
[Musik]
das hat sich jetzt wirklich gut
verbunden und jetzt gebe ich noch ganz
fein geschnittene ersten dazu
[Musik]
aber eins zu eins aus wie das innere von
yogurette horror so und das will ich
jetzt hier einmal rein wundert euch
nicht es wird noch mega fest während der
kühl zeit und so ein bisschen glatt
streichen könnte das auch schon mal
entweder geduldet ihr euch und macht
nach vier stunden weiter oder also ich
mache es über nacht und dann würde ich
mal sagen nachdem ich das klappt
gestrichen hat sehen wir uns einfach
morgen wieder und dann mache ich nach
den schönen abschluss
wir haben es jetzt den nächsten tag und
ich habe über nacht ehrlich gesagt
überlegt mache ich jetzt ein schokokuss
mache ich einen erdbeer groß ich habe
mich dann entschieden weil der advan
liebe natürlich auch schokolade
aber es ist ja gerade saison und falls
jetzt keine frischen erdbeeren nehmen
dann könnt ihr zudem muss natürlich auch
tiefgekühlte erdwärme nutzen
ich habe jetzt schon mal vom grün
entfernt sage ich mal und in stückchen
geschnitten es gebe ich es direkt in
meine fahne ihr könnt natürlich auch
gerne einen topf nehmen du bist die
pfanne genommen damit ihr besser rein
gucken können da gebe ich jetzt wasser
dazu und je nachdem wie süß oder auch
nicht eure erdbeeren sind noch so ein
bisschen zucker
das macht es so einfach nach gefühl aber
ich habe ich sowieso die ganz genauen
mengenangaben und in denen die wasser
als mr oder was jetzt nehme ich mir
meinen pürierstab also der hat es noch
nicht eingeschaltet und püriert das erst
mal und danach ruhig speisestärke ein
und lass das ganze aufkochen
[Musik]
nachdem der erbbau groß aufgekocht ist
blickt er direkt ein ich habe den jetzt
persönlich noch mal 10 15 minuten stehen
lassen damit er nicht ganz so heiß auf
die joghurt schicht kommt in der
zwischenzeit könnt ihr schon mal eure
dort eine schöne platte legen und dann
den bus drauf geben
bei mir war's jetzt noch mal für zehn
minuten im kühlschrank denn erst jetzt
kann ich den ring entfernt da für mich
wie immer mein backform löser dann würde
ich mir da auch nicht so wegreißen und
dann der kurieren wir einfach nur noch
nicht für die deko übrigens für weiße
schokolade entschieden natürlich nochmal
frische erdbeeren für yogurette und was
ich mir noch gedacht habe ich nehme noch
so ein paar frische blumen mit dazu
[Musik]
große magneten
doch ich habe einen kuchen gebacken ja
hallo ich karibik stiftung gehöre wissen
oder zu laut waren gedanke ist auch die
skizzen druck ach so es ist ja dann ist
er noch kühler kosovo also mit
familiengeschichten er leuten während du
probiert unten haben wir ein cacau
butterkeks boden dann haben wir eine
richtig schöne joghurt schicht mit apple
hat typische uhr edt und ein erdbeer
abschluss und jetzt probiere ich auch
mal also wusste ich jetzt nicht das
risiko reduziert heißt und wo ich würde
sagen er ist mit diego riether ja oder
wegen den kö-bogen sich ja das kabinett
vorgesehen das ist durch moritz
irgendwas schokolade ist musste ich drin
haben und wollte keinen schulabschluss
weil es sollten leichte torte werden und
die schmeckt total erfrischend nicht so
süß aber ich will auf den zug kann ich
nochmal reduzieren ich reduzierte
ohnehin schon oft der ist einfach nicht
zu sich
also ich glaube dass mehr gehabt hättest
du so richtig wohl gebracht und show
geboten wenn er nicht so zum geschmack
so durchgekommen die devise boden wo ich
kann voll gut beschreiben
man könnte auch schon eigentlich kann
ich irgendwie wie gar nicht schlecht
also man könnte auch ein schoko boden
backen aber ich bin zum sommer hat es
bessere passieren aber ich finde dieser
bundes intensivem geschmack also geboren
macht auf jeden fall super gerne nach
toll und ich würde sagen wir sind später
gibt es zu diesem tag machen willst in
der disco gelernt man in einer klasse
aber es ist natürlich gut auf mein
abitur ihren herzlichen glückwunsch
immer schon gemacht und wir hatten nur
einen tag kritik an diesem tag den wir
damit vor
ok diese voll cool sind auch so jung hip
und ja auch wild und so auch
ja wenn ich nicht also leute periode was
das kino
also leute in diesem sinne einer woche
nein abonnieren und kein licht
bis dann das und die schwindende augen
ja ich
[Musik]